today to talk about privacy and the
complexity of simple queries
uh it's a single talk session
okay uh
thanks everyone for coming uh okay well
echoly
thanks everyone for coming so i'm really
excited to be here this is my second
live talk of the postcovid era so i'm
still very happy to be able to give live
talks
um
i will say first i'm doing a couple
things i've never really done before in
a talk like this the first is that i'm
wearing a mask so if you're having
trouble like hearing me or if i'm kind
of mumbling or something please let me
know
the second is i see now that everybody
likes to doodle on slides by hand so i'm
kind of upping the game by doing
entirely handwritten slides i've never
done this before i hope i haven't been
this self-conscious about my handwriting
since eighth grade
i hope that it comes out okay but please
let me know uh if you can't read
anything or if you need me to just like
rewrite something or zoom in or you know
whatever
um
right we're saying this is basically
what all talks were
this is what all talks were in your day
right it was handwritten slides
projected
um
my dad still has a lot of his
actually sorry
[Laughter]
i've never personally witnessed the talk
given on an overhead projector
sorry elias
i'll give you a recap later
okay so uh the other thing i'm doing
that's a little different so
um
this is on rigorous evidence for
trade-offs between for information
computation trade-offs
and uh sam emailed me and said john
you're really bad at making things
efficient so maybe you could tell us
about that
and
i said sure that's a great way to invite
someone to give a talk
so i will do that so i'm not really
going to talk about like a specific
paper or anything terribly recent
um what i'm going to do is i'm basically
going to talk about one
open problem in the area of differential
privacy that is uh something that's been
kind of at like the
the center of a lot of research so it's
sort of one problem that kind of drove a
lot of the research on the topic at one
point
and where progress is kind of stalled
and what i'm going to do is i'm going to
sort of like describe the problem and
kind of what we know about it and how we
sort of got to like that problem
and then i'm going to describe what we
do know about it
and the kinds of approaches people have
applied and sort of where they got stuck
and
in the process i'm not going to be able
to give you a lot of rigorous evidence
for information computation trade-offs
i'm going to be able to sort of point
you to a problem where this phenomenon
currently arises
and i think the people in this room and
the people watching on zoom at least
those who can hear me not ilias can
possibly help
so
um as a result basically i'm gonna be
sort of telling a story it's not gonna
be a very technical talk and so if you
ask me
any questions that would be great like
the more sort of interactive this is i
think the more
uh everyone will learn from it including
me
so
let's begin so what's what's like the
high level story of the problem
that we're trying to solve
so
uh we're gonna start out with just like
a very basic setup for like statistical
estimation we have some population p
we draw some sample x
for today you know you can just think
you can definitely just think of
id samples
and we want to make use this sample to
make some conclusions about the
population so this could essentially be
anything right it could be some
estimate of the mean of the population
it could be some predictive classifier
um some hypothesis test
it's uh you know really in this level of
generality it's really not important
what it is
and
the goal of course is not to learn
anything really about the sample per se
the goal is to learn about the
population
but
the sample we collect are consists of
real people's data so for example
um some of this stuff has come up in the
context of working with the census
bureau where
the data set of course is you know
actual people whose doors were knocked
on and had to fill out a card
um
or users who use some you know some
system like google or facebook and
want to uh have that data used in a
certain way
so
from the perspective of the person
analyzing the data the goal is just to
learn about the population but the way
we're going to do that is we're going to
use a sample which represents real
people's data
and so we have to protect the privacy of
that data so we have to ensure that we
learn about the population in a way that
doesn't reveal too much about the people
actually in the sample
and
like at first flush this sounds
like a great situation because what what
we're trying to do make conclusions
about the population
is sort of perfectly aligned with the
privacy goal we really only want the
sample as a means to understanding this
population in fact in in some sort of
sense really our goal is to avoid
learning anything that is just specific
to the sample and only to learn things
that are true about the population
right so for example i might want to
learn
the sort of canonical example is like i
might want to learn that uh whether or
not you smoke is correlated with whether
or not you're going to get lung cancer
at some point in your life
but
if i'm trying to conduct a study to find
that out i really don't inherently care
about any one person whether they smoke
or whether they have cancer in fact my
goal is not to learn about one person in
the data set it's to learn about the
population
so
you might think that there's just not
even a problem here maybe a
well-designed
estimator or machine learning algorithm
would inherently respect the privacy of
the sample because in order to do a good
job of learning about the population it
should not be overfitting to the sample
but
in fact
most out-of-the-box statistical methods
um do reveal a lot of information about
the individuals in the sample sort of in
non-obvious ways so
um you know i'm not talking about
methods that sort of output say a
representative data set where that data
set obviously contains individual
samples
even methods that reveal something like
regression coefficients or the
parameters of a predictive neural net or
the mean of the data set
can reveal a lot of information about
the samples
in fairly surprising ways
and often inherently do so so often
there are sort of inherent requirements
that any
good method for inferring something
about the population must in fact reveal
a lot about the sample
so this has been formalized or observed
in like many different contexts
um i'll point to a couple
lines of work
so the sort of whole field of
differential privacy was kind of
launched by a paper on something called
reconstruction attacks
uh by dinora nissim this is like a
seminal paper that has been really
influential in data privacy
and
what it basically showed is that for
many natural estimation problems you can
just sort of reverse this process
or to a large extent you can reverse
this process and go from
some seemingly benign looking output
like some some population some output
that describes the population back to
the sample or a large part of the sample
that was used to produce it
in the context of
high-dimensional statistics there's been
a more recent line of work on something
called membership inference where
you don't reconstruct the data set but
you can sort of identify whether or not
a person was included in the sample
which can be itself a privacy violation
um this sort of began with an
influential attack uh it's referred to
as homer at all on genomic data sets
um
and also in the machine learning
community people have started to look at
uh in some ways sort of more blatant
types of privacy violations where kind
of large
uh neural networks will effectively
remember training data so
the predictive model when kind of used
in the right way you can actually
extract from its specific examples it
was trained on so kind of you know high
entropy unique examples that really like
don't reflect any sort of population
trend they really just reflect like one
training example in the world
um
so that was first shown in a paper
called the secret share by carlini at
all but it's become sort of an active
general area of research and there's
been an interesting line of work on sort
of to what extent
machine learning in certain
settings essentially requires this type
of memorization
so
um you know the gist up to this point
right is that there are
there's a sort of a rich theory of
attacks on privacy routes for breaching
privacy
from
seemingly fairly benign
uh statistical
and
the kind of conclusion is that unless
you explicitly do something to rule
these types of attacks out they'll
probably be possible so
uh the kind of subtext of a lot of this
work
most of these papers sort of begin with
somebody proposed a heuristic to prevent
privacy violations and
lo and behold another attack was
possible so there should really be some
kind of rigorous way
of arguing that not only these attacks
don't work but sort of a broad class of
attacks are not possible
and
for the past 15 years
uh the
kind of criteria that's emerged is
something called differential privacy
so the paper that introduced this was by
dwarf mcsharing seaman smith in 2006
um
and it's been a very active area of
study and what it
is is basically
a certain kind of robustness condition
that an algorithm can satisfy
um
so the idea is suppose we have a data
set x so that's the top data set here
and you know hypothetically you're like
some person in this data set so just
imagine that you are a person in this
data set and you're a little worried
about your privacy
and we're going to run the data set
through some kind of mechanism for some
reason algorithms in this literature are
called mechanisms uh i tried to change
this and a journal reviewer told me the
ship had sailed and i needed to to stop
doing that so i've just given up but for
some reason algorithms are mechanisms in
this literature
so you're going to run the data set
through some mechanism and it's going to
produce some conclusion whatever it is
maybe something about the population
but it really doesn't matter some
conclusion
and
you're worried that that conclusion will
reveal something about you
but
you're not just worried that it'll
reveal something about you right so
you're worried specifically that it'll
reveal something about you
because you agreed to have your data
included in this computation so
um this is sort of an important
idea that we're going to consider a
counterfactual where we ran the
mechanism on the same data set
except we've taken your data out of it
or we've maybe replaced it with some you
know dummy record or something but we
basically stripped
anything specific to your sample out of
the data set
and
we want to argue that
the conclusion that we reach
should not depend in a significant way
on which of these two
cases we're in whether we use the real
data set or whether we use the data set
with u stripped out of it
and
what that means is that
no
attacker should be able to learn too
much about you because your data was
sampled okay so the fact that you were
sort of one of these unlucky people who
was actually included in the sample
should not cause
any attacker to learn too much about you
and in order to get that we have to
formalize a particular condition on the
mechanism that says that these two
worlds are indistinguishable
okay and so
formally this notion of epsilon delta
differential privacy
says that for every two data sets
that differ on one person's data so not
just your data but you know any one
hypothetical person's data
and every possible event on the output
space that could arise
the probability of that event
when the mechanism is wrong with your
data so on x
shouldn't be too different from the
probability of that event when the
mechanism is run
with uh this hypothetical data set x
prime
and at that level of a you know
generality
this just says that the distribution m
of x and m of x prime have to be close
in some sense
but
for reasons i'm not going to get into
but that are important there's a very
particular notion of closeness that's
used in epsilon delta differential
privacy
and its form is really important
so if you ignore this delta for a second
the notion of closeness is that the
ratio of the two probabilities should be
upper bounded by something a little
bigger than one
okay so for technical reasons we
typically write it as e to the epsilon
but epsilon should be fairly small so
think of this as like
you know should increase by 10 at most
for sort of technical reasons we also
add this extra additive term of delta so
it says for really really unlikely
events we don't really care about the
point wise ratio of probabilities
and you should think of delta as this
like very very small quantity
um
but
the key thing is really this
multiplicative ratio of probabilities
so
this is um
what i like to think of is it's a notion
of sort of distribution stability or
distribution robustness it says if i
change one person in the data set
let's say you
then the output of the mechanism
shouldn't change much like in
distribution not just in sort of
symmetric but actually as probability
distributions and this is what gives it
these kind of strong semantic guarantees
okay so
let me go on and let me describe like a
problem that's been sort of at the heart
of research on differential privacy so
like i described this definition there's
been a lot written about why this is a
good definition and what it means so
of course what what would we like the
mechanism to do
and so a problem that's received a lot
of the attention is coming up with
differentially private algorithms that
answer statistical queries about the
population so if you've heard of the
statistical queries model from kearns in
93
um
this is essentially what i'm asking is
can we implement the statistical queries
model via a differentially private
algorithm if you've never heard of this
at all that's fine let me just be very
concrete
so we have some distribution p
over some data universe u which for
today i'll just think of as plus minus
one to the d so you know d bits so
everybody in your
world answers d yes or no questions for
example and that's that's your data set
and
we have some queries we'd like to answer
and the queries have this very specific
form we just want to estimate
the mean of some function over the
population and the function is going to
be for today like a plus minus one
valued function
and it's not really important like some
of these details are you know more just
for concreteness but some bounded
function
so
for every query qj i'll say like qj of p
is the expected value of this predicate
q
on a random point from the population
i like to abuse notation a little bit in
this way
and this capital q is going to say well
i have a vector of k of these queries
and q capital q is going to be like just
the the function that concatenates the
answer to all of them just to keep
notation a little simple
um
and then i have a data set that's drawn
id from my distribution p and the goal
is i'm given a bunch of these queries so
there's no like interaction at all
there's just a set of k queries
and i want to design some estimator m
such that
if i give it n samples from any any
distribution p
it approximates this
capital q of p fairly well
for today the notion of approximate is
going to be
i want to
get something that's close in l infinity
distance so for every query i want to
get something that's within about one in
a hundred you know just make a little
the answers range between minus one and
plus one so i wanna get some kind of
non-trivially good answer for every
query
some of the technical statements i make
are going to be like a little fuzzy and
fast and loose with whether i want say l
infinity or l2 or
l1 you know i i wanted to give something
concrete but
you can study this of course in like
lots of different metrics you know you
can look at different regimes i don't
want to kind of go into everything
okay so this is a canonical problem this
lets you do lots of things so it's like
seems very simple but if i give you
enough queries you can do all kinds of
things
so let's look at just a couple of quick
baselines for what you can do in this
model
so the obvious baseline if you don't
care about privacy is just to use the
empirical mean so just pretend your data
set is the population
and
uh
just
look at the mean of the queries on the
data set and return that as if it were
the population now obviously a lot of
the you know talks in this workshop are
about how hard it can be to infer
something about the population given
samples even in the absence of privacy
constraints but for this problem
the
non-private version is basically trivial
so if i get i guess the way i wrote it i
need maybe log log of the number of
query samples but
the gist is that
a very small number of samples will
suffice and we want to know how does
adding a privacy constraint make this
problem harder so we're starting with a
problem that's
essentially trivial from a
in for you know without a privacy
constraint both information
theoretically and computationally
okay so there's kind of nothing
interesting going on without privacy
so there's a very simple baseline
mechanism that does satisfy differential
privacy it's what sort of emerged out of
the early line of work it's like you
know it's a little hard to figure out
exactly which paper did it this way but
the gist is that it's it's what's
advised out of the day one of
differential privacy
so
you take the empirical mean this is like
a vector in k dimensions of you know
it's a vector with answers to k queries
and you just perturb it with gaussian
noise like independent gaussian noise on
any coordinate so you perturb it with
like spherical gaussian noise
and
if you perturb it with enough noise i
mean it's sort of obvious that as you
crank the variance up to infinity
eventually you lose all information
about the empirical mean so it should
become private the question is how much
noise do you have to add
and the answer turns out to be that the
amount of noise you have to add to make
this differentially private
is
um about square root of the number of
queries over n
so if there's n samples so it says as
you add more samples you can add less
noise but as you add more queries you
have to add more noise
and
you know i think that uh it's not
terribly insightful to like analyze this
for you but the gist is that
changing one person in the data set can
only change the empirical mean by a
small amount in say l2 norm because
i'm taking an average of n people if i
change one person i can only change the
empirical mean
um
by about
root k over n
and so what this says is if i get about
root k samples
i have enough to estimate the answer to
my queries privately
so this is a you know a big gap so even
if i had maybe put this union bound in
it would be that log k samples without
privacy and suddenly i need square root
of square root of k samples with privacy
okay so that's a very big gap
but it turns out that you can do
like much much better than this so i
again i'm not really going to go into
the algorithms exactly although i will
give like a taste of how they work um
in in the next part of the talk
but
if you imagine you're in a setting where
you have way more than d queries you
have a data set of dimension d
but you're asking you know way more than
d queries like d to the 10 or even you
know exponential and d queries you can
do much better
so
um what emerged out of sort of the
second wave of differentially private
algorithms starting with a i think a
really influential paper by blum liggett
and roth but with like many subsequent
algorithms that refined their ideas and
gave very very beautiful new ideas
so if i give you any set of these
queries
to any set of k queries
there's a differentially private
algorithm
that accurately answers all the queries
given a sample of size about square root
of the dimension
okay so it's like it's not a direct
improvement on what we had before now it
depends on the dimension but when the
number of queries is much bigger than
the dimension
this says that the sample complexity can
be almost independent of k so again i'm
like hiding a log factor okay but
the point is that we can go from square
root of the number of queries to just
square root of the dimensions so we can
answer
even like an exponential number of
queries in the dimension without really
paying much for it in sample complexity
but
perhaps unsurprisingly given the preface
to this talk
the
big downside of this kind of second wave
of algorithms is that they're not
computationally efficient
so
if you think about the
simple bass line i described the
gaussian noise edition
basically the bottleneck in the
algorithm is just evaluating all the
queries
right so like you start by writing down
this vector with answers to all k
queries
and
um
then you just add you just perturb them
all with noise so basically the
bottleneck is how fast can you write
down the queries
now like the way that i've written the
problem the queries themselves could
take exponential time and d to evaluate
right i just said you have some
arbitrary function that maps
d bits to one bit
so nothing actually says that even
without privacy i can do that in
polynomial time but
the way also to think about the running
time of this gaussian mechanism is that
once you're done writing down the
queries which for most natural cases
would actually be very efficient the
additional time to make it private
is
just sort of linear in the number of
queries it's just add a gaussian to
every query
on the other hand
these other algorithms the running time
is always exponential in the dimension
so like
even if the queries are extremely simple
to evaluate even if there's just you
know d squared queries
the running time to
get these to add the noise basically to
get the answers to the queries to be
private
will require exponential time in the
dimension
okay so
you know once this picture sort of
crystallized it became clear that
there's some interesting like
computational versus information
theoretic phenomenon going on
and so people of course started to ask
you know can you do
any better
and here's kind of like the picture that
we got to
um
so people started asking you know can
you just
get like a third wave of algorithms
that's just efficient and works for all
queries so can you sort of do better for
just worst case queries like any any
queries you can possibly imagine asking
and what sort of emerges that the answer
is no
so
if you sort of look at my like my table
um what it basically says is that if you
want a polynomial time algorithm you
need
the number of samples to grow square
root of the number of queries if you're
willing to have an exponential time
algorithm it can just grow square root
of the dimension even when you have many
more you know a huge number of queries
and
people were able to show that this was
sort of best possible so
the best results in this line of work
sort of the information theoretic
question can you just get rid of the
square root of d completely can you get
you know
o of one just a constant number of
samples so we were able to show in a
paper with markbone and sulifidon that's
not possible so if you want to answer a
lot of queries even information
theoretically you need about square root
of d samples when the number of queries
is bigger than d
um
but also computationally we were able to
show a pretty big gap
so in work with luke kowalczyk and tom
malkin and mark hendry we showed that
um
if i give you k like arbitrary queries
they can be anything the only constraint
is that they have to be
themselves something you can evaluate in
polynomial time so i don't want a hard
problem just because the queries
themselves are hard to answer
um
so there's a set of you know for every k
there's a set of k polynomial time
sampleable queries
uh or polynomial time evaluatable
queries where the number of samples you
need is polynomial and k so i i don't
know how to get exactly k to the one
half
but
polynomial and k so we were able to show
like k to the one seventh where there's
nothing special or interesting about
seven
um
so
what this picture kind of says is that
for the most part we sort of understand
the worst case complexity for the of
this problem where worst case is like
worst case over data sets and over
queries or sorry over like worst case
over populations and worst case over
queries
and there's definitely interesting open
questions here so trying to understand
for example
uh you know like for what types of
queries can you get around this root d
lower bound information theoretically
um
but the sort of like research thrust
that i think has been most interesting
and where i think there's a lot of a lot
of unresolved questions is basically
when can you improve the computational
complexity so when can you get
when can you eliminate these information
comp information computation trade-offs
or show that they're inherent
by assuming like more structure in the
queries so
assuming that you're not just answering
these arbitrary queries defined by some
arbitrary predicate on the domain but
something very you know very simple with
some structure
and
i think by far like the
case that's received the most attention
in the sort of computational picture
is this example it's called the sort of
m way marginals or you could also things
like the the moments of the distribution
those might call emway parity queries i
think moments is actually the thing
that's probably like the nicest one but
i'll stick with emwa marginals because
it's just what people have been doing
so
these queries are like a case that was
sort of
has been around since basically the
beginning of differential privacy it was
kind of motivated by applications in the
the census
but
it has you know an extremely simple
description for like the tcs community
basically
um
i have some parameter m think of m as a
constant let's say
and
for every
s i have a domain of size 2 to the d so
if my domain is d bits
and for every subset of m coordinates or
at most m coordinates
i want to know the expected value when i
draw a point from the population
of the product of all of the coordinates
in
the set so for example s if m is 2 s is
like all for all pairs i j i want to
know the expectation of x i times x j
so this is really just asking for
the
like m order moments of the distribution
what is the
why does this come up in the census what
is the
right okay so um
basically like what does the census
release right so they collect from
people
uh
a relatively small number of attributes
so they collect from people like which
census block you live in which is a way
of encoding your address
and
uh
some representation of
your sex and your age
and um
some race ethnicity and the types of
things they release are things like
you know in
census block 1402 how many people are
uh non-white and of voting age and so
this is this is this is intersections of
a small constant number of attributes
exactly yeah so it's like the things
they release it can be called these sort
of marginal tables where you're
basically just asking for like
a description of the marginal
distribution if i look at you know
voting age non-voting age now the main
difference is that there you typically
don't have binary features
um but you know this is a like this is
the fundamental problem at the core of
what they're trying to do
um they're often also not interested in
releasing like every single one of these
they're interested in some you know
particular subset of interests or not
every set s of size up to
m but like some particular set but i
think like as stylized as this problem
looks i mean i think this is extremely
fundamental and really does sort of
capture the difficulty in
a lot of the work like they do in
practice so i do think it's like quite
connected to the practice of
differential privacy but of course also
i mean this captures things like
you know again if you relax like binary
features it's like what is the
covariance matrix of the distribution
it's kind of hard to have a more natural
problem than that i mean even if you do
have binary features you can ask that
question but like
um it's a special case of just like what
is the covariance of the distribution
so
um
so this is basically the the problem
that i i claim is sort of open it's
basically how do you answer these
queries
in a differentially private way
and
uh just to see what the actual question
is so let's sort of look at what our two
types of algorithms give
so if i want to do
gaussian noise addition
well the number of queries here is about
d to the m
and so that algorithm will use about d
to the m over two samples so something
exponential in m
and even if you think of m as a constant
right this could be some large
polynomial in d
and the running time um you know again
as long as m is reasonably small and
we're willing to just write down all of
the say three-way marginals then this is
a very efficient algorithm
and of course ask if you can do
something even more efficient than that
but let's not go there
um these more advanced mechanisms say it
doesn't matter what m is there's maybe a
linear and m term here that's hiding but
for any constant m i can get d to the
one half samples but my running time is
now exponential in d
and i think i'll have enough time to
sort of show you like specifically where
that comes up
so
this is kind of the the state of the
world and like the question that i i
propose that you know people study and i
would love to chat about that people
look on is basically are there
computationally efficient algorithms for
privately releasing
m way marginals let's say for any
constant m
with
optimal sample complexity or even just
sort of much better than d to the m over
two so there's been a little progress on
this but not too much
and
uh
the only time i've ever proposed a
reward for an open problem
uh
i the reward was that i will go out to
you with you and thomas danke for all
you can eat sushi at a particular
restaurant in boston and two people
simultaneously solved that problem they
have not claimed the prize because of
like kovit and stuff but
uh i figure i have a good track record
so
i will go out for sushi with you you
have to take like we go together though
you can't just like take the sushi with
someone else does thomas stanky still
live in boston it might be a long flight
for him no a lot has changed since we
proposed this reward yeah it could be
really hard it was the reward seemed
much easier to give out before when we
actually gave them
but it does seem to prompt progress on
problems and i get to eat sushi
um
okay so this is the problem so let me
just describe like a little bit of the
kinds of things that people look at and
i think
at the time people were looking at these
things um
you know i think people are taking very
different approaches so i wanted to kind
of translate some of the algorithms that
people have looked at into
things that might be uh that feel
like active areas of study where i think
people like in this room might be
overused so
um there's sort of a line of work that i
think kind of
kind of started from a paper of mine
with anupam gupta and moritz hart and
aaron roth
um
where we tried to basically resolve this
problem using algorithms from
uh learning theory from like
pac-learning theory
and
there's kind of a simple idea at the
core of this
so it is to sort of flip the problem
around a little bit so
the
func we're going to try thinking of a
function
that takes as input a query so in this
case like it takes the description of
like a three-way marginal so like three
coordinates as input and what it returns
is the answer to that query
okay like that's a perfectly
well-defined function
and
we're going to try to apply learning
algorithms private learning algorithms
to that function
and
why is that useful well what does a
learning algorithm do so it gets to see
points on the function which in this
case means random queries right a point
on the function is like a query so i'll
sample some random queries
and i'll show you
the answer to the random subset of
queries
okay and the thing that makes learning
algorithms good is that they need many
fewer samples than the input size of the
function so even though there's lots of
queries a good learning algorithm for
this problem
would be able to take the answer to a
small number of queries
and extract from it the answer to all
the queries
now i need to give you private answers
to the queries in the sample
and i can do that using the gaussian
mechanism if the number of sampled
queries is very small
so like if you only sample maybe d
queries
then
i can
show you the answer to all the queries
in the sample with just uh sorry i
should not be overusing samples so
let's say there's example queries those
are like the points here you get to see
then i want to give you an estimate of
the value of the function on that query
using my data set my sample data set
and i can do that by adding gaussian
noise to the answers and there's a small
number of queries so i don't have to add
that much noise
and then you're going to try to figure
out what the answer to the rest of the
queries is so kind of the standard
learning paradigm you're going to try to
fit a function that agrees with all of
the queries you've seen so far
and hopefully also generalizes to unseen
queries
and
as you know there's a trade-off between
the function class
and the sample and computational
complexity so
um
you know in fact you can basically get
optimal algorithms just by noting that
there exists
a way there's an information theoretic
way to do this using only about d
samples for the class of queries i
described
but the learning problem wouldn't be
solved efficiently but we were able to
give um say non-trivial algorithms this
way
so
for example using sort of techniques
based on chebyshev polynomials we're
able to show that you can
uh improve the sample complexity to
something that's b to the order square
root of m the sub exponential in m with
about the same running time so the
running time i guess is still d to the m
uh to write down my queries but the
running time overhead is smaller
so
i mean the point is not so much to go
into this result but this is like a
paradigm for how you might try to solve
this problem you can cast it as a sort
of private learning problem
where you're trying to come up with an
efficient way of seeing the answers to a
small number of these marginal queries
and you're somehow trying to infer
answers to the rest of the marginal
queries accurately
um
and
that approach sort of stalled out
and with the benefit of hindsight i
think the reason that this approach
stalled out is because it's essentially
like an instance of this noisy tensor
completion problem so if you
think about what this function is for
marginal queries it's like i give you m
coordinates
and then i ask you to tell me
the product of those m coordinates and
then average over elements of the
population
so what this function really is is it's
like
the the function that tells you a
certain coordinate in this like
rank one
or the convex combination of rank one
m's order tensors
so that's a problem that's been studied
of course um
i'm sure there are people in this room
who know more about this problem than me
but
the sort of punchline is that
information theoretically if i give you
about order d entries in this tensor
there's actually a way to recover the
missing entries you can complete the
missing entries in the tensor
but
um
at least what i know about this problem
is that there's a paper by barack and
mantra showing that under certain
refutation assumptions
any computationally efficient algorithm
for
tensor completion even with a third
order tensor requires
it has to see about d to the three
halves entries of the tensor
and that sort of translates to saying
that if you're working in this framework
any private algorithm would have to have
a sub-optimal sample complexity which is
at least d to the three-fourths
okay so you know already but if you
could get d three-quarters for m equals
three this is already better than your
naive thing right it is would have been
three halves the naive thing would have
been three halves yes so you can do
better and i mean there's a
the converse to this is that you can
basically take an algorithm for tensor
completion and you can actually get you
should be this is an upper bound as well
in general right yes in general b to the
m before
so um
and that is no i mean i guess as i said
this is the
state of the problem i didn't say that
there were some non-trivial upper bounds
uh one of them i stated on the last
slide one is this one you're basically
figured out but
um
yes basically this says you can't get
better than d to the omega m using this
like
um
[Music]
using this approach at least for
constant
okay so this is one place where there's
kind of a like a barrier is that this
approach seems to be
running into this barrier which is this
like tensor completion barrier so
there's some
rigorous evidence for
information theoretic trade-offs in
information computation trade-offs in
tensor completion
uh which only capture this one style of
algorithm so let me describe i've got
like eight minutes left so i'll sort of
describe one other style of algorithm
very briefly and then
okay
you know the point is basically i've
been you know doodling slides for the
last 18 months with no one to show them
to so like i could be talking forever if
no one cuts me off
okay so i'm gonna describe one other
approach that comes from a really
elegant paper by nikola caldwell and
john
that is
i think spiritually quite related but it
has some slightly different features
that make me think it's interesting to
study
so it their mechanism is called the
projection mechanism so
they don't cast the problem as a
learning problem
what they do
is they say
let's just start with the trivial
algorithm so let's just start by taking
the uh
we'll just write down
all d to the m answers to the queries
and we'll just use this gaussian
mechanism
and we'll add so much noise that it's
private like anyway so even though we
have to add a lot of noise in fact when
the number of samples we have is small
we have to add so much noise that the
answers don't even live between negative
one and one anymore they're like totally
you know way outside the realm of
plausibility
but what we'll do is we'll say okay you
know good so our answers are not
consistent with any
actual distribution these cannot
actually be the nth moments of any
distribution anymore they've completely
lost their like tensor structure
so let's basically just project back
into the set of
answers we could have gotten that are
actually consistent with some
distribution
so you can define this polytope k
and
this polytub k it's just sort of the
it's the set of possible answers you
would get to all of the moment queries
if these were the real answers on some
population
so it's like a polytope that's like the
convex hull of two to the d different
vertices each one each is defined by a
vector and plus minus one to the d
so i started with
my my true answer here it's this blue
dot y
i've like added some crazy amount of
noise to make it private so i have this
point y tilde that doesn't even live in
k anymore so let's just project it back
into the polygon and like in the obvious
sense like in l2
and
first thing actually the one nice
property of differential privacy is that
once i have the purple point i can do
anything i want to it and it will remain
differentially private it's closed under
post-processing
so
privacy analysis is basically just this
purple point sort of trivial
the question then is is this red point
y-hat actually closer to y than i
started
by like a non-trivial amount
and the answer is yes if this polytope k
has low what's called gaussian width
so
the what you can show is that the
distance between the blue point and the
red point
is proportional to the gaussian width of
this polytope and
the gaussian width if you haven't seen
it it says
i draw a standard normal g
and i look at the largest inner product
of g with anything in the polytope
in absolute value and i look at the
expectation over g of that quantity
so it's like a relaxation of having
bounded diameter
and
what you can show is that as long as k
has bounded gaussian width small
gaussian width
this will be very accurate it will be
information theoretically basically
optimal so
what's really surprising is that i'm
taking this mechanism that adds such a
crazy amount of noise that the answers
look useless but they're actually enough
information theoretically to recover
very good answers in fact information
theoretically the best answers we could
get with privacy
so
uh i'm sorry i should say so obviously
this projection is not efficient because
this is projecting on to the
convex the convex hall of you know third
order tensor is defined by like a binary
vector
but we can try some sort of relaxation
and
um
our goal could be to find some sort of
efficient relaxation of this set k that
also has low gaussian width and emits
efficient projection
and
in a fall paper dork nikolov and talwar
found such a relaxation based on on stps
and it doesn't quite give d to the m
over four it has this sort of you know
parity issue it gives like d to the
m over two ceiling over two
but
you can use sort of you know fancier
ideas to get it down to like d to the m
over four so
it's basically d to the m over four i'll
say morally m over four one particular
consequence is this does give an optimal
algorithm for m equals two so for the
second moment case we have an optimal
algorithm but it's still not optimal for
m equals three and higher
okay so these are basically the
algorithms we know and you know you can
see like this i think sort of progress
on this runs into
trouble in a similar place that progress
on
noisy tensor completion runs into
trouble but it's like less
the the connection to refutation i don't
actually know that it goes through so i
think there's one sort of nice question
there is could you show for example that
anything in this framework
uh cannot be efficient and optimal say
under these like refutation assumptions
i don't know how to do that
but it seems at least closer to
something that we could study
so i will
uh sort of wrap up there with this
question
and let me just make sort of like one
observation about kind of like why i
think we're sort of stuck on these
problems so like where i think the
kind of conceptual bottlenecks are
so the first one
is like a little flip but it's sort of
that i think we sort of used up all the
cryptography and proving the worst case
lower bounds so what i mean by that is
sort of like an analogy to say
learning theory so if you look at the
history of proving hardness results for
pac learning
where
similar types of problems arise
the history was sort of like
very shortly after pac learning was
defined
uh it was shown that if you believe in
cryptography like if there's
pseudorandom functions then there's some
learning problem that you can
information theoretically solved but you
can't solve efficiently and once you
sort of like know what a pseudo-random
function is it's like basically a very
very easy simple reduction you sort of
use like the minimal amount of crypto
that you can imagine
like minimal in the sense of like you
need about one week of cryptography
class to get there
um then if you want to show things like
it's hard to learn
um
you know intersections of half spaces
and stuff you start introducing
like
fancier cryptographic instructions and
uh public key encryption schemes with
nice properties and pseudorandom
functions that are can be evaluated in
very low complexity
um
but you have a lot of room for that
because like the base hardness that sort
of the worst case hardness for some
worst case concept class
was using only the simplest crypto
uh in differential privacy even to show
the worst case hardness results i
described you actually need like
basically
like all the crypto you need
indistinguishability obfuscation is the
current state of the art which is like
the uber crypto assumption
um
and so
we've kind of you have to use so much
cryptography to like try to understand
even the worst case complexity of these
problems like worst case over queries
that you just don't really have a lot
left to there's not a lot of tools left
to use
that's in some sense like more of a
sociological statement than a technical
statement but i think it's sort of like
meaningful that it's just very hard to
even figure out like what
types of like assumptions in crypto or
primitives and crypto would be useful
for showing that these problems are hard
um
answer two which i think is almost like
total logical you say it is like we just
don't really understand much about how
privacy restricts the types of
algorithms you can you can use
so
right like in all of the problem in all
the types of frameworks i described what
we're doing is we're like tying our
hands in some way
so we're saying let's like replace the
data set with some let's sort of imagine
that we just have some sort of simple
oracle like we get to see the answers to
a
small number of marginal queries or we
get to see answers to
uh yeah it's like a small number of
queries or we get to see very very very
noisy answers to all the queries like
we're tying our hands and we're saying
we'll tie our hands in such a way that
we can sort of implement
this
oracle access to p
in a private way
using like one of the few like out
really like using the very simple
private algorithms we know so like just
using the simple idea of adding gaussian
noise
and
we'll basically ask like what can we do
with that so if we get this very limited
access to the population
you know what can we do with that
but in reality like we actually have
this sample
like like we have it like it's staring
us in the face right we have the whole
thing and we're in a regime where
the sample and the population are
basically interchangeable it's not
really hard to infer things about the
population from the sample
and so
the only thing that's like stopping us
is that we have to use the sample in
like a private way and we just don't
really have a good handle on like what
type like how can we access the data
to make it like privacy friendly so we
know there's things we can do but we
don't really have a good
characterization of like what
you know how does it limit you so it's
really hard to come up with like
reductions to say
hard learning problems or hard robust
statistics problems or any kind of heart
inference problem
because sort of as far as you know like
the sample is just this thing you hold
right like you can sort of in principle
you can sort of do most things with it
you just have to do private things we
just don't really have a sense of like
what makes an algorithm private so of
course in some sense this is like a
tautology like we don't know how to
prove lower bounds because we don't know
what the set of algorithms is but i
think there's something like
conceptual here about why it's very hard
to even come up with like a candidate
reduction from some of these problems to
say like
planted problems or refutation problems
so i think that's kind of where we're
stuck and hopefully i inspired some of
you to think about this
so i will just stop there and take
questions
oh i have some questions so like in the
definition of the private sv model you
will only allow for oblivious queries
but if i want to make adaptive queries
where like the second query depends on
the first one does that totally change
the picture or what happens
yeah so great so it's one of the slides
that i basically did so so basically
yeah so the way i defined it like we
just have a fixed set of queries there's
just i want marginals
um you can of course imagine that i sort
of treat the
data set as like uh something you can
access interactively so we do know a
little more about that like we know that
that problem
is in some sense harder like it's easier
to prove lower bounds
um
but
it's also in some sense like
so it's something that's just harder
right so it's easier to prove lower
bounds
it's in some other sense like it can be
you can think of it as easier in the
sense like maybe i have this huge set of
marginals there's like d to the 100
marginals but i don't want to answer all
of them i just want to let you ask me
for like a subset of them so you can get
into a realm where you could also
imagine that it's like easier the short
answer is it's kind of just a different
model we have um
you know i would say that when you start
thinking about these questions about
like nice queries it's a little less
natural like i let you ask any query you
want if it's a marginal query maybe i
should have just answered all the
marginal queries in the first place
but it is definitely something you can
study we do know that in the worst case
um it's very hard basically if i'm going
to let you ask vk arbitrary queries
you can't answer more than yeah i need i
need root k samples to to do that is
true even without differential privacy
or ah good question so that's actually
so one of the reasons i didn't talk
about it's actually much less that
problem is much less well understood
even without privacy
um but the short answer is
um
[Music]
if the dimension is unbounded you might
actually need root k
samples without privacy so
the
lower bounds are in some sense less
striking like we have the similar lower
bounds but it's less clear that you
should have been expecting to solve that
problem effectively
yeah
in the census situation you described
where you do want to answer marginal
queries but actually it's only for
certain subsets of the i don't i don't
actually need all the unwise marginals
can you take advantage of wanting
suppose there's
you know
a relatively small number of my
marginals that you actually want to know
can you take advantage of this well so
if the total number you want to know the
answer to is smaller than d
then you're sort of back in the case
where you just have a small set of
queries they might as well even be worst
case periods
um
but even then i guess the thing that
they sort of want to do the thing that
you still sort of want to do in practice
is enforce these consistency constraints
so
uh so even if you're in this regime or
you have fewer than d queries
if the queries are overlapping in some
way you should be getting uh some
benefit out of like having these
consistency constraints
and there um
even if you have a small relatively
small number of these uh marginals it
may be it may still be hard to
like find a consistent data like a
consistent set of answers
uh it's essentially can sort of be
thought of like inferring a sparse
graphical model or something like that
so it's it's a
problem where
sort of more even hope to do but there's
still some hardness there
and also relatedly again back to the
sentence motivation it seems like there
uh
some of some of the
some of the attributes have like a
really large number of possible values
and some have much smaller you know like
which census block there's a lot of
census blocks uh which which um
many other many other attributes have
fewer possible answers although maybe
some of them should have more than you
are allowed to give on the census but
right so for example
the census has males and females maybe
that should be for race and ethnicity
then there's like 63 i think possible
ways of answering the the race question
which is still way less than the number
of census blocks so
does can these methods take advantage of
there being
fewer or like what happens when you have
a lot like really a large number of
possible values for it seems like it
gets very different from binary answers
when you have yeah okay so i guess i
should say so for the blocks thing
really what they want is more of like a
histogram like they want
some set of queries
but answered on like every individual
block so there's not a lot of like i
want all the blocks that have the bottom
number because that's not like a
geographically meaningful thing
so forget the blocks then for a minute
but within a block you're right so you
have a group in various ways like you
don't really care about ages and years
you mostly care about they use for
example fight your blocks
and things like voting age non-voting
age
um so you can do a lot to explain that
so even if you have say like you know
imagine the only thing you care about is
representing the age distribution like
you just want to get say the cumulative
distribution function of ages there's a
lot of very non-trivial stuff you can do
that's like a problem that's been
studied a lot and then you can sort of
imagine studying the problem of like
i want to get sort of uh
a table of like within each
racial category what is the cdf of the
ages and now you have sort of like a
marginal but where one of the features
is not binary
um
imagine
like some more complicated problems
explicitly but
yeah you can definitely get into an
interesting territory where you can do
very interesting things with like
univariate attributes and then you can
imagine sort of marginals of univariate
attributes
john can i ask a question
sure mystery person
yeah i'm pravesh sorry i'm joining on
zoom all right
uh yeah this is about this dnt uh this
even versus odd issue that you were
pointing out
um
and so if i understand correctly or is
the following understanding of the
problem correct so i have um d to the
one point five i don't know d to the one
point five log d
uh of the triples like you know three
wise marginals right and i have like an
independent gaussian and i would like to
certify a good upper bound
uh you know via some efficient
relaxation on the gaussian linear
combination of this due to the 1.5 log d
marginals and their arbitrary marginals
is that
correct like if i could if i could get a
relaxation that gives me a good value
for this then you know it would imply
that the gaussian width of the polygon
you were defining is like certifiably
small
would that mean that we resolve this
just i think it's just that he wants a
uh
some some some relaxation of the set of
distributions
with the
small gaussian width the realization of
the set of ky's moments
with small gaussian with it's it's um
it's refuting random random gaussian
polynomials yeah
right that's a good thing just refuting
random gaussian polynomials as opposed
to so i i guess
so just to confirm it seems like the
monomials in your case are not random
right so that's a semi-random part right
like the monomials are arbitrary the
coefficients are random
so in the point in the version i was
describing you get all its d you get all
d to the d cubed entries
with like a ton of noise i see so it's
like it's not even like semi-random it's
like you have all the monomials i see
but with random coefficients
i see
i see
okay
and and but they're like so we you you
want to it's not sort of the even odd
thing so like if you have d though
if the gaussian width is whatever gives
you like a d to the 1.5 algorithm then
we know how to get that via like
reduction to tensor completion what i
want is like d to the 1.4
i see okay okay thanks
but i'm confused about the connection
with tensor completion right now so so
as you said if i have
um i look at the set of all uh order m
moments
and let's say that i i just looked at
the empirical needs over a population of
size
uh people what do we call the size of
the
it's just a population like it's an
infinite population
the sample size is like n but okay but
like i'm saying it's without loss of
generality the sample size can be fairly
small okay so whatever that samples
whatever that effective sample size is
then this set of all amps order
moments is a
tensor whose rank is that sample size
but then we add gaussian noise to it
yeah
but um
when you said tensor completion i
thought that meant like you're going to
tell me
the values or the noisy values of a
certain number of these moments yeah and
from that i'm going to reconstruct the
rest yes so there were two frameworks so
one of them is basically i give you a
subset
of
entries of the tensor with a small
amount of noise
that's a tensor completion problem yes
but what i'm saying is you know tensor
completion like that is the problem we
have here
i hold the data set so i could i could
give you the full tensor but to do it
privately i'd have to add a ton of noise
to it right so there's like a spectrum
of like i could either give you a small
sub sample of the entries with a little
noise or i could give you all the
entries with a lot of noise
and i only know the connection to tensor
completion if you decide you're going to
give me a small sample
but in principle you could get a private
algorithm in this thing you described
which is not tensor completion and
that's sort of what what profession is
asking obviously
so i'm curious about this effective
sample size because that's like getting
a low rank approximation to the true
uh correlation tensor or whatever we
call that the moment answer yeah
yeah so i guess for that since i'm
interested in an entry-wise error
i guess you can just always like sample
uh like one if you want say like
alpha error for every coordinate you can
sample like one over alpha squared
elements from your population
uh log of
log of the number of moments for a union
bound
and that would give you
the right that that would be accurate so
it says there exists a
tensor of rank about one over alpha
squared
that would
d over alpha square that would
approximate entryways
it's specific to the fact that i want to
approximate entry once if i wanted like
a
approximation say like if this were like
the matrix setting and i want to
approximate like for being a norm
i guess
for things those are great questions
awesome
all right classes